en 2014 un groupe de musique appelé
vulpec a gagné 20000 dollars avec un
album inattendu intitulé sleepify et
pour bien vous rendre compte du style
musical très particulier de sleepify je
vais vous le jouer maintenant malgré les
risques d'infraction au droit d'auteur
oui vous avez bien entendu cet album à
20000 dollars n'est autre que du silence
alors techniquement je vous ai passé la
chanson et je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit plus représentative de l'album je
crois que en particulier c'est peut-être
plus représentatif même si ce n'est pas
tout à fait ma chanson préférée de
l'album
et comme vachement bien mais comment
est-ce possible comment est-ce possible
que ce silence soit aussi lucratif et
bien comme vous l'avez peut-être deviné
ce n'est pas parce que les abonnés de
Spotify ont payé leur abonnement pour
pouvoir écouter du silence plutôt que de
la musique ce qui s'est passé c'est que
le groupe vulpec a demandé à ses fans
d'écouter ce silence en permanence y
compris pendant la nuit pour augmenter
leur nombre d'écoutes et récupérer ainsi
plus de recettes via le système de
paiement de Spotify vulpec a exploité la
faille des fausses écoutes au niveau se
dit
[Musique]
en fait aujourd'hui on va voir que ces
fausses écoutent sont désormais un enjeu
qui représente littéralement des
milliards de dollars alors que la fraude
massive parfois s’écoute est devenue une
économie importante qui biaise toute
l'offre musicale au profit des escrocs
désormais professionnels mais surtout
pour contrer la fraude il existe une
parade que Deezer cherche à adopter
depuis 2016 et 7 ans plus tard s'amusant
à l'application traîne encore et qui est
un principe fondamental de la recherche
en sécurité des intelligences
artificielles que des collègues et moi
avons formaliser dans un article publié
en 2022 aujourd'hui on va parler de la
théorie de mathématique des IA
équitables et sécurisés que mes nombreux
co-auteurs et moi avons développé depuis
maintenant 7 ans et qu'on a peaufiné et
optimisé notamment pour la plateforme
tournesol
alors la manière dont les recettes de
Spotify sont distribuées est en fait
très opaque il y a clairement des
arrangements spécifiques avec des aéants
droits puissants notamment les grandes
maisons de disques comme Warner musique
Sony musique ou Universal Music par
opposition notamment aux indépendances
mais une composante clairement majeure
de la distribution des recettes Spotify
est un système parfois appelé marketing
payment system en gros dans ce système
les abonnements des consommateurs sont
tous collectés et regroupés dans un
énorme pot commun puis chaque ayant
droit est rémunéré à hauteur de son
nombre d'écoutes totales relativement au
nombre d'écoute des autres ayants droits
et techniquement une écoute c'est la
lecture d'une piste audio pendant au
moins 30 secondes ce qui explique
pourquoi les chansons de l'album
sleepify de vulpak font toutes 31
secondes et pourquoi les musiques sur
ces plateformes ont tendance aussi à se
raccourcir et le problème que ceci pose
c'est que comme on l'a vu ce système
permet aux utilisateurs de manipuler
aisément les recettes des artistes pour
favoriser les artistes qu'ils préfèrent
vous voyez comment et bien en abusant
simplement de fausses écoutes pour les
artistes que vous préférez par exemple
en ouvrant un onglet Spotify en mutant à
l'onglet et en jouant la musique de ces
artistes vous pouvez augmenter
artificiellement leur temps d'écoute en
laissant typiquement tourner en boucle
pendant toute la nuit autrement dit
c'est comme si vous aviez plus de droits
de vote sur la redistribution des
recettes en écoutant davantage Spotify
alors depuis le cas de vulpec les
services de streaming ont des
algorithmes anti fraude qui détecte et
annule les tentatives grossières de
manipulation du système de paiement mais
bien sûr les fraudeurs se sont adaptés
et ils ont maintenant largement
automatisé l'écoute des contenus tout en
la rendant suffisamment réaliste pour ne
pas se faire détecter je vous invite
vivement à lire en particulier cette
enquête glaçante de Philippe Astor qui
décrit toute une industrie de la fausse
écoute que le journaliste qualifie même
de mafia et dont certains très grands
artistes semblent être des clients
d'ailleurs ce hack fut même organisé et
faciliter par l'application eternify
développée par un autre groupe de
musique en protestation avec le manque
de protection des petits artistes pour
contrer cette faille du système de
paiement Deezer a annoncé vouloir passer
à un système de paiement dit user
centric selon ce système les abonnements
des utilisateurs sont plus regroupés
pour chacun des utilisateurs son
abonnement est réparti en fonction
uniquement des écoutes de l'utilisateur
en question en plus d'empêcher la triche
par fosse écoute ce système très simple
et naturel semble aussi plus équitable
la répartition des recettes dépend en
effet alors bien moins de ce qui coûte
les très gros consommateurs des
plateformes de streaming en fait avec le
système user centric chaque utilisateur
contrôle qui sera financé par ses
propres abonnements l'utilisateur ne
rémunère que celle et ceux qui
l'écoutent paye ou you play comme le dit
Deezer malheureusement malgré des bonnes
volontés chez Deezer qui appelle à
adopter le système userentric depuis
2016 10 heures n'a pas encore
transitionné vers ce système quant à eux
Spotify et Apple semblent très réticent
à changer de système et il y a une
raison très simple à tout cela ce
changement de système revient à
redistribuer les richesses différemment
ce qui entraînera inéluctablement des
gagnants et des perdants selon une
simulation du Centre national de la
musique le rock et la pop ils
gagneraient au détriment du rap et du
hip-hop une étude les chercheurs de
l'université de Hambourg confirme cela
avec notamment une perte estimée après
de 90 millions d'euros pour le hip-hop
et le rap allemand par opposition à des
gains importants pour le rock le métal
et le classique mais du coup certaines
grandes maisons de disques risquent d'y
perdre beaucoup et comme celle-ci ont un
pouvoir de marché particulièrement
important en menaçant notamment les
plateformes de streaming de les quitter
le statu quo semble difficile à faire
évoluer de façon un peu plus spéculative
on peut aussi imaginer que les très
grands artistes qui utilisent déjà les
services du cybercrim et en particulier
des fausses écoutes pour amplifier leur
nombre d'écoutes et donc leur popularité
perçue ces artistes influencent
également probablement les maisons
d'édition pour empêcher l'évolution du
statu quo et ce phénomène est
particulièrement insidieux sachant à
quel point l'apparence de succès est un
facteur majeur du succès en musique
comme l’ont montré notamment salgannick
dot et what en 2006 dans une expérience
répliquée depuis notamment par Mehdi
Moussaid dans une excellente vidéo
floscopie en particulier en manipulant
les algorithmes de recommandation
l'impression de succès peut être boostée
et ainsi permettre un succès effectif un
journaliste qui a enquêté sur ce
phénomène affirme ainsi avoir reçu
l'offre suivante pour 12000 euros une
agence de publicité lui promettait un
million de vues sur YouTube dans un
contexte où la fraude est facile et peu
combattue l'argent fait littéralement le
succès qui lui-même fait beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent plus généralement la
manière dont les activités des
utilisateurs sont agrégés pour prendre
ensuite des décisions sur le
comportement des algorithmes des
plateformes c'est un aspect critique
pour la sécurité et l'équité et donc
l'éthique des systèmes ainsi conçus et
tout ce que je dis là dans le cas de
redistribution des recettes Spotify
Apple et Deezer s'applique tout autant
au cas du machine learning
quasiment tous les livres les cours les
articles et les séminaires de machine
learning vous trouverez l'hypothèse d'un
pot commun de données et l'objectif
d'apprendre de l'ensemble de ce pot
commun sans prêter attention à qui a
fourni les données qui rentrent dans ce
pot commun ou pire encore ce pot commun
est parfois remplacer par une mystique
distribution de données dont les données
utilisées pour entraîner l'algorithme
serait tirer indépendamment et de
manière identiquement distribuée comme
j'en ai parlé dans une vidéo précédente
cette hypothèse dite iid est l'une des
plus irréalistes et des plus dangereuses
hypothèses standards du machine learning
l'autre hypothèse dangereusement
politisée étant l'objectif de
généraliser les données collectées qui
est clairement un parti pris pour le
statu quo et les idées les plus
populaires pour se rendre compte de
l'inadéquation de l'hypothèse iid il
suffit de revenir en cas de Spotify le
pot commun des temps d'écoute représente
en fait très mal l'usage de Spotify mais
surtout tout mettre dans un même pot
revient à survaloriser les utilisateurs
qui ont une consommation énorme de
Spotify et à essentiellement ignorer
ceux qui ont une consommation plus
occasion après tout comme on l'a vu il
suffit d'écouter davantage Spotify pour
influencer davantage la redistribution
des recettes Spotify autrement dit on
peut identifier deux failles au problème
du pot commun à savoir d'un côté le
problème de l'équité et de l'autre le
problème de la sécurité la faille
d'équité est ce que je vais appeler le
biais d'activités les utilisateurs plus
actifs ont un pouvoir disproportionné
comparativement aux utilisateurs moins
actifs et notez que le problème ici
n'est pas restreint aux plateformes de
streaming musical tout projet
participatif est exposé au risque de
biais d'activité y compris et peut-être
même en particulier les débats
politiques typiquement dans une
délibération ceux qui parlent davantage
risque de davantage influencer l'issue
de la délibération pour contrer ce biais
d'activité des mécanismes comme le vote
sont souvent critiques en appliquant
notamment le principe une personne une
voix et pas plus qu'une voix l'autre
faille qui est donc une faille de
sécurité est l'incitation aux activités
factices armée de fermes de troll ou de
bottes les acteurs malveillants peuvent
acquérir un pouvoir disproportionné et
prendre le contrôle du système en place
ça pour toute application populaire et
déployée sur le web il faut absolument
se rendre compte que c'est la norme pour
rappel l'industrie du cybercrim s'est
estimé à 6000 milliards de dollars soit
4 fois plus que Google puisse Apple
puisse Facebook plus Amazon plus
Microsoft et comme on l'a vu dans la
première vidéo de cette série chaque
année Facebook retire autour de cette
milliards de faux compte ces deux
problèmes le biais d'activité et
l'incitation aux activités factices sont
déjà alarmants dans le cas des
algorithmes de langage qui est en
l'absence de fine tuning et de pré
prompt ou lorsque le fentuning et le
prétent sont inadaptés pour un prompte
d'un utilisateur vont se mettre à parler
comme les contes les plus actifs sur les
réseaux sociaux le font ou comme le font
les campagnes de désinformation armée de
fauconques mais ces deux problèmes déjà
avérés pour le cas des algorithmes de
langage deviennent absolument
catastrophiques dans le cas des IA les
plus puissantes du monde à savoir les
algorithmes de recommandation de YouTube
Tik Tok et Instagram qui décide tant de
l'exposition informationnelle répétée
quotidienne de milliards d'humains sur
terre même si ces IA souvent conçus avec
des hypothèses moins naïfs que
l’hypothèse ID elle subissent un énorme
biais d'activité surtout lorsqu'elle
favorise les contenus en tending et par
ailleurs elles sont clairement
extrêmement vulnérables aux fermes de
trolls et de bottes notamment parce que
la création de compte y est très facile
et sans doute désormais très largement
automatisable via les algorithmes
génératifs comme chaque GPT et midjorn
mais alors que faire comment corriger
les systèmes d'apprentissage pour qu'ils
évitent le biais d'activité et
l'incitation aux activités factices dans
la vidéo précédente sur les maths
dédiées à démocratiques on avait vu un
bout de la réponse en limitant l'impact
maximal d'une donnée mais clairement
ceci est insuffisant sachant qu'il
suffirait alors d'injecter plus de
données pour acquérir plus de droits de
vote et bien avec mes collègues Sadek
farad Kany Oscar villemo et rachidiarawi
on a fourni une solution très propre et
finalement très proche du système de
paiement userentric dans un article
accepté en 2022 à la conférence ultra
prestigieuse acml donc j'avais fait un
vlog il y a plusieurs mois
l'idée centrale de notre solution c'est
d'isoler les données des différents
contributeurs et de faire en sorte que
l'ensemble des données d'un contributeur
est un impact limité sur l'apprentissage
d'un algorithme de machine learning
typiquement le gradient et vous pouvez
sauter à la prochaine minute à venir si
vous êtes en Palise de terminologie le
gradient associé à l'ensemble de ces
données doit être normalisée et rendu de
normes égales à 1 avant d'affecter un
algorithme d'apprentissage et si on
considère un norme chidienne on tombe
exactement dans le cas de la médiane
géométrique autrement dit de manière
approximative il ne faut pas prendre la
médiane géométrique des données il faut
prendre la médiane géométrique des
utilisateurs voilà qu'il garantit
vraiment la propriété d'équité invotant
une force unitaire et comme on l'a vu ce
principe est accompagné de propriété
vraiment pas dégueu en termes
d'incydation alors dans le cas du papier
icml pour des raisons techniques et en
particulier pour avoir des fonctions
localement fortement convexes on a rusé
et on a remplacé les forces unitaires
par des forces quasi unitaires obtenu
avec une normalisation euclidienne lycée
plutôt qu'avec la normalisation
euclidienne qui a par ailleurs d'autres
avantages combinaison peut oublier ces
détails techniques pour aujourd'hui en
fait les systèmes de paiement
marketentric et user centric sont
intimement liés aux problèmes de
robustesse discuter dans notre article
le système marketing est alors
équivalent à prendre la moyenne des
vecteurs d'écoute et des abonnés à la
plateforme de streaming puis à répartir
la recette de manière proportionnelle à
ce vecteur d'écoute mais si vous avez
suivi la vidéo précédente vous savez
très bien que cette solution est très
mauvaise car la moyenne est très
manipulable typiquement en exagérant le
vecteur vers la direction qu'on préfère
ce qui dans le cas du streaming revient
à faire beaucoup de fausses écoutes pour
les artistes que l'on veut booster à
contrario le système user centric est
équivalent à d'abord normaliser les
vecteurs d'écoute des différents abonnés
ensuite prendre la moyenne des vecteurs
incidentalisés et à payer les artistes
proportionnellement aux vecteurs moyens
ainsi calculer alors techniquement ce ne
sont pas les artistes qui sont payés
directement sont lésés en droit
typiquement les maisons de disques des
artistes et c'est eux qui ont surepé les
artistes sont vraiment pas importantes
pour cette vidéo alors mathématiquement
en fait pour être plus précis dans le
cas du système univers cent
[Musique]
dans ce cas même si je les écoute tout
autant en temps normal j'ai tout intérêt
à essayer de truquer le système en
votant entièrement pour le sosie de lait
par exemple avec des faux écoute parce
que bon c'est sympa 30 secondes mais il
chante un peu faux comme je l'avais dit
dans la vidéo précédente s'il faut
répartir des budgets au moins d'un point
de vue sécurité et éthique du vote et en
oubliant la difficulté d'explicabilité
pour le plus grand nombre la solution
que je préconise c'est bien plus la
médiane géométrique notamment à cause
des propriétés de robustesse d'incitatif
alignés avec l'honnêteté de localisation
dans l'enveloppe convexe des votes
reçues un petit peu technique à
expliquer aux gens mais c'est vraiment
des bonnes propriétés mathématiques pour
des systèmes participatifs d'ailleurs
dans le cas en particulier du streaming
d'autres considérations pourraient aussi
entrer en jeu comme ne pas trop
valoriser la vie d'une personne qui n'a
fait qu'une écoute dans l'année le fait
de soutenir des artistes indépendants et
de leur garantir un salaire minimum
quitte potentiellement à limiter les
recettes mirobolantes des méga artistes
ou encore le fait de valoriser les
artistes de musique qui améliorent le
bien-être des consommateurs et diffuse
des messages positifs pour la société
tout dépend par exemple de ceux qui
pourraient appeler à la N et environ
surtout lorsque c'est en vert certaines
minorités
[Musique]
en fait l'algorithme qui détermine la
répartition des recettes des plateformes
de streaming et plus encore l'algorithme
de recommandation qui met en avant
certains contenus plutôt que d'autres et
qui va être du coup déterminer le succès
des artistes c'est on ne peut plus un
objet politique en soi qui va déterminer
la survie économique des différents
créateurs de contenu les habitudes de
consommation audio d'un demi milliard
d'humains et les cultures musicales
prédominantes aux quatre coins du monde
et donc tous ceux dont on a parlé dans
la série sur la démocratie mais aussi
dans cette série sur l'éthique de
l'information s'applique à ses
algorithmes des plateformes de streaming
et bien entendu tout ceci s'applique
aussi en particulier à tournesol cette
plateforme qui vise à concevoir un
algorithme de recommandation sécurisé et
éthique en s'appuyant sur des principes
de gouvernance démocratique et surtout
nos sols justement l'agrégation des
contributions des contributeurs s'appuie
sur une autre normalisation encore à
savoir la normalisation elle infinie bon
je ne l'ai pas entrer dans trop de
détails pour aujourd'hui on y reviendra
longuement mais en gros surtout nos sols
pour chaque vidéo qu'il ou elle a
explicitement jugé chaque contributeur
au contrib son fils en gros tirer le
score de cette vidéo vers le score qui
loue elle juge être le score adéquat de
la vidéo avec toujours une même force
unitaire si on l'appliquait à Spotify ou
à 10h cette normeisation revient à vous
demander pour chaque artiste si vous
pensez qu'il devrait être payé plus ou
moins qui ne l'est actuellement chaque
utilisateur tirer alors la recette de
cet artiste vers le haut ou vers le bas
ce qui pose bien sûr un autre problème
qui est que du coup la recette totale
reversée ne sera pas forcément la somme
des recettes collectées mais bon surtout
nos sols on n'a pas ce genre de problème
puisque voilà
reverser score pas de l'argent ceci
étant dit même sur tournesol ce principe
de vote par norme à l'infini ne marche
pas si on l'applique naïvement ainsi
obtenir une démocratie algorithmique
vraiment satisfaisante nous a fallu en
fait développer depuis maintenant trois
ans une toute nouvelle théorie des votes
sécurisés et équitables notamment dans
un contexte creux et qui tient désormais
dans plusieurs articles de recherche et
qu'on continue à améliorer chaque jour
notamment en cherchant à intégrer des
concepts qui nous semblent importants
comme la volition le vote baïsien ou
encore la ainsi liquide d'ailleurs
dernièrement on a fait des progrès assez
excitants dans la théorie de conversion
des comparaisons dans ce corps qui
s'appuie désormais sur des mathématiques
incroyablement élégantes donc j'ai
également très hâte de vous parler bref
si tout ceci peut sembler très technique
et malheureusement c'est en effet assez
technique il me semble vraiment s'agir
de préoccupation fondamentale à avoir au
moment de la conception de tout système
participatif surtout lorsque les enjeux
sont aussi massifs que le discours
politique en démocratie ou la lutte
contre les déviances autoritaires mais
pour continuer à développer ces outils
tournesol manque cruellement de main
d'oeuvre et on a désespérément besoin de
plus de moyens financiers et humains le
salaire de notre unique développeur
n'est pour l'instant assuré que jusqu'à
août fort heureusement nous avons
maintenant la chance d'avoir l'aide et
le soutien financier d'infomaniaque une
entreprise éthique dont je suis heureux
de vous parler sur scène for all à
l'heure où les systèmes d'information
sont trop souvent aourcés à des tiers
qui exploitent vos données et les
données de vos entreprises pour
entraîner des algorithmes génératifs à
tout va il est devenu urgent de
considérer que des plateformes comme
slack google doc ou autre Microsoft sont
des spyware en puissance à contrario
Infomaniak fait un effort majeur pour
tout développer de manière souveraine
avec des collaborateurs uniquement en
Suisse un pays beaucoup plus digne de
confiance notamment par opposition aux
entreprises américaines soumises au
Patriote vous pouvez d'ailleurs profiter
gratuitement des services mails et
suisses Transformers et je vous
recommande aussi vivement le service
d'hébergement Web camites ou encore ca
Drive pour chaque vidéo où je promeut
info maniaque ce que je fais avec grand
plaisir infomaniaque reverse un don à
l'association tournesol merci beaucoup à
Infomaniak pour ce soutien
si je récapitule on a vu aujourd'hui que
très souvent les statistiques étaient
agrégées sans se soucier de leurs
origines et des décisions importantes
avec parfois des milliards de dollars en
jeu sont prises à partir de ces
statistiques agrégées j'espère que vous
retiendrez qu'il s'agit là d'une très
mauvaise façon de faire aussi bien sur
le plan éthique que sur le plan de la
sécurité au lieu de cela et à l'instar
de ce que toujours la liste et
scientifique apprend pour des questions
de sécurité notamment il est critique de
prêter attention aux sources des données
et de juger à la fiabilité des données à
la lumière de ses sources
malheureusement faute d'analyses
critiques de ces aspects et parfois
poussé par la corruption et l'incitation
à déployer rapidement des technologies
spectaculaires les industries du
numérique ont tendance à favoriser des
solutions très insatisfaisantes qui ont
pourtant déjà des conséquences majeures
sur des économies entières comme
l'économie des artistes indépendants
dans le cas des plateformes de streaming
ou dans le cas de chaque GPT et Tik Tok
sur l'économie massive du cyberculing
sur la cybersécurité du tissu économique
à travers le monde sur les capacités
cognitives de milliards d'humains sur
les sujets qui vont devenir ou pas des
sujets d'actualité en démocratie il est
urgent d'exiger beaucoup plus de
sécurité et d'éthique dans la conception
des systèmes d'information en
particulier non ce n'est pas parce qu'il
s'agit d'algorithmes que c'est neutre ou
sécurisé faire l'hypothèse IUT ou
généraliser les données collectées c'est
normalisées le statut quo rien que
calculer une moyenne plutôt qu'une
médiane c'est déjà favorisé l'industrie
du cybercrim malheureusement y compris
dans les grandes entreprises du
numérique l'expertise en mathématiques
de la sécurité et de l'éthique est
extrêmement rare notamment car dès qu'un
mathématicien s'y intéresse on lui dit
qu'il sort de son champ d'expertise
voire on le traite d'idéologues oui je
parle d'expérience personnelle et de
façon anecdotique j'ai été traité
d'idéologues juste après avoir vu cette
vidéo de Florian Kova qui explique que
traiter les scientifiques d'idéologues
étaient une stratégie des campagnes de
désinformation de l'industrie du tabac
je ne peux que vous encourager à ne pas
laisser ces sujets en suspens et
encourager vos proches vos collègues vos
entreprises et vos régulateurs en faire
de même et pour monter en expertise sur
ces sujets
tout le contenu que j'ai produit
gratuitement mais sachez que vous pouvez
aussi compter sur notre entreprise
quelle CARPA cofondé par trois experts
du domaine et qui offrent du conseil et
de la formation pour vous et vos équipes
je vous invite par exemple à prendre
contact avec moi si vous souhaitez faire
profiter vos équipes de nos services
pour les éviter de tomber dans les
nombreux pièges de la cybersécurité des
intelligences artificielles dont même
les ingénieurs de Samsung sont des
victimes le développement du numérique
est encore un énorme Far West qui ne
cesse de considérer que les enjeux de
sécurité d'éthique et de gouvernance
sont secondaires et ne méritent pas une
attention centrale j'espère que je peux
compter sur vous pour ne pas tomber dans
ce travers pour au moins faire vos
premiers pas vers la construction d'un
numérique peut sécuriser plus éthique et
plus collaborativement gouverné